if you're playing a video game and the
the way to win the game was to make the
most successful character you would have
probably a really character-driven human
being in terms of like they'd be patient
they'd be hard working you think about
all these traits that they would have
right they'd probably be tough
emotionally like Etc cool that's the
character and that's the person who's
going to be really successful we can all
probably agree on that how do you create
someone who's patient how do you create
someone who's tough if we had to then
engineer the game in order to boost
those points we'd have to get them beat
up a lot so that they could get tough
we'd have to make them wait a long time
so they could become patient that's
right and so these people who become
really successful have these traits and
also share the fact that they've been
through all this and you know
what's crazy if you really think about
that and break it down every time you do
get over you actually end up
being the person that won